SPEWING IS TIME FOR OUR
"SEEN AND UNSEEN" SEGMENT.
WHERE WE EXPOSE THE BIG CULTURAL
STORIES OF THE DAY.
AND FOR THAT, WE TURN TO RAYMOND
ARROYO.
RAYMOND, THE AMERICAN -- HAVING
THEIR ANNUAL CONFERENCE.
AND THEY VOWED YESTERDAY TO SICK
LAWYERS ON PARENTS WHO HAVE
OPPOSE CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
>> AND TODAY AND THE NAME OF
HONEST HISTORY AND PROMOTING
CRITICAL THINKING, THE UNION
INVITED A DOCTOR TO ADDRESS
THEIR TEACHERS.
>> WE LIVE IN A DANGEROUSLY
RACIST SOCIETY.
THERE ARE RACIST IDEAS THAT ARE
SWIRLING AROUND, THAT ARE
TEACHING DARKER SKINNED KIDS
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG
WITH THEM BECAUSE OF THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN.
THERE ARE IDEAS THAT ARE
SWIRLING AROUND TEACHING WHITE
KIDS THAT THERE IS SOMETHING
RIGHT ABOUT THEM BECAUSE OF THE
COLOR OF THEIR SKIN.
>> LAURA, THERE'S A SIMPLE
RACIAL LESSON WE SHOULD LEARN.
WE ARE ALL CHILDREN OF GOD.
WE LOOK DIFFERENT, BUT WE SHOULD
LOOK INSIDE THE PERSON AND WATCH
THEIR ACTIONS, JUDGE BASED ON
THAT, NOT ON THE EXTERNAL
WRAPPING.
THAT'S ALL A CHILD NEEDS AT THAT
POINT.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF ITS MADE
THIS STATEMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NOT
TAUGHT IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS OR
MIDDLE SCHOOLS WERE HIGH
SCHOOLS.
>> BUT TODAY DURING THEIR CLOSE
BREAKOUT SESSION, RACIAL
DIVERSITY AND WHITE CULTURE,
USING PICTURE BOOKS WERE
ANTIRACIST TEACHING.
THE AFT WEBSITE DESCRIPTION
READS "IN THIS SESSION WILL
ADDRESS TACTICS AND TOOLS THAT
TEACHERS CAN USE TO PROMOTE
ANTIRACIST TEACHING METHODS FROM
READING CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
BOOKS TO LEARNING ABOUT IMPLICIT
BIAS IN THE CLASSROOM."
SO THE UNION SUGGESTS USING THIS
-- IT'S INTENDED TO FOUR TO
8-YEAR-OLDS.
IT'S CALLED SOMETHING HAPPENED
IN OUR TOWN.
AND IT IT FEATURES A COP
SHOOTING.
THE BOOK SAYS "THE COP SHOT HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS BLACK.
THEY DON'T LIKE BLACK MEN."
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IMPACT
DOES THIS HAVE, THIS KIND OF
STORY, ON A CHILD'S ATTITUDES
TOWARD POLICE?
AND CONTRARY TO WHAT THE DOCTOR
SAID, THE BOOK LEADS WITH SKIN
COLOR IS BEING DETERMINATIVE OF
WHETHER A PERSON IS GOOD OR BAD.
THIS IS NOT WHAT KIDS NEED TO BE
MARINATING IN AT SCHOOL.
>> Laura: WELL, ASIDE FROM ALL
OF THAT, WHICH IS -- HIS
COMMENTARY THAT HE GET PAID
HANDSOMELY FOR IT, I CAN EVEN
IMAGINE HOW MUCH HE GETS PAID
FOR MOST OF IT.
HE SAYS RACISM IS SWIRLING
AROUND TEACHING.
AND WHAT KIDS ARE TAUGHT THEY
ARE RIGHT BECAUSE OF --
WHAT IS HAPPENING QUESTION MIKE
I THINK HE NEEDS TO START NAMING
THE SCHOOLS WHERE THAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENING BEFORE HE ARRIVED
ON THE SCENE.
THE AFT IS ALSO RECOMMENDING THE
PICTURE BOOK, NOT MY IDEA, IT'S
ABOUT WHITE MEN.
IT TEACHES WHITE KIDS THEY HAVE
PRIVILEGE AND CONTRIBUTE TO
WHITE SUPREMACY.
RAYMOND, YOU HAVE TO CHECK YOUR
WHITE FRAGILITY RIGHT HERE,
RAYMOND'S.
>> AGAIN, WE ARE DOING EXACTLY
WHAT HE IS CONDEMNING.
BUT WE ARE TEACHING MY KIDS THEY
ARE BAD BECAUSE THEY ARE WHITE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN -- WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN,
LAURA, WE NEED TO SHOW GREAT
BLACK AND WHITE LIES,
ABOLITIONISTS AND FOUNDING
FATHERS LIKE JOHN ADAMS, AND
PEOPLE LIKE NAT KING COLE AND
LOUIS ARMSTRONG AND SPORT STARS.
WE NEED TO SEE THE FIRMAMENT OF
THE RACES THAT MADE AMERICA WHAT
IT IS.
AND LET KIDS MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION.
THEY WILL SEE THE STRUGGLE AND
THE PROGRESS.
I WENT TO SHOW YOU THIS.
THIS IS A MINNEAPOLIS TEACHER
AFT TEACHER AT THE TOP OF
TONIGHT SESSION.
LOOK.
>> I'M JUST A SCHOOLTEACHER.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT WE WOULD BE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A REVOLUTION.
BUT KNOWING THAT WE HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF THE UNION, MY FELLOW
TEACHERS, I AM SO PROUD.
>> Laura: IS THAT THE
SYLLABUS?
SHE CAN DO WHATEVER SHE WANTS IN
HER PRIVATE TIME OR PROTEST OR
WHATEVER.
THAT'S FINE.
BUT IS THAT THE CLASSROOM?
OR ARE WE JUST DISPENSING WITH
FORMAL TEACHING COMPLETELY?
AGAIN, MUCH OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS RACIST, THEY CLAIM IT'S
ANTIRACIST, EXECUTRIX.
MOST OF IT IS RACIALLY EFFECTING
KIDS MIND-SET AND I THINK -- A
LOT OF IT IS VERY NEGATIVE AND
IT'S SAD.
I THINK IT'S SAD.
THERE ARE GREAT BLACK WRITERS,
GREAT BLACK THINKERS, ALL OF
THEM SHOULD BE HIGHLIGHTED